It's great to welcome back to the program,
Thom Hartmann, who's the host of the Thom
Hartmann program and also author of the new
book The Hidden History of Monopoly's How
Big Business Destroyed the American Dream.
Tom, as always, great to see you.
Thank you, David.
The book has a forward by Ralph Nader two,
which is the forward is almost worth the cost
of the book.
That is I.
I've actually spoken to Ralph Nader about.
About this issue and made many people I mean,
maybe a good place to start is I don't know
that everybody understands how far back monopolies
and monopolistic behavior by firms in the
United States goes.
You talk about it dating all the way back
to the revolution, which may surprise some
people.
Yeah.
The Boston Tea Party was a revolt against
a monopolistic company.
The East India Company was the largest monopoly
in the world at the time.
They had monopolized tea in the United States
along with a lot of other things.
It was illegal to manufacture fine clothing
in the United States, for example, certain
types of weaponry, certain certain types of
furniture.
They all had to be manufactured in England
and imported via the East India Company.
And so when the depression or recession of
1770 is the t.k, the East India Company petitioned
the British government for basically some
cash.
They were stretched and the British government
said, we'll give you a refund on millions
of dollars or the tea that you've got in today's
dollars that you have in an inventory, because
they back then they paid tax when they received
the tea from India, not when they sold it.
And so the East India come to get this huge
multi-million dollar tax rebate that allowed
them to drop their price on T into the United
States and compete with the with the American
Smugglers', which made the American people
just furious.
And thus the Tea Party in our nation was birthed
in a revolt against corporate monopoly.
When we think about the different times in
American history where there's been more of
a focus on trust busting and going after monopolies,
are there certain industries that have regularly
sort of skirted the the scrutiny that maybe
they deserve?
Well, there are some industries that have
been better at it than others, and that tends
to have to do with how much political power
they have, which is usually a consequence
of either financial power or essential industry
banks or pharmaceutical companies, for example.
But, you know, the simple reality is that,
you know, just like cancer in the body is
when one cell decides I'm going to take over
the entire body and starts growing and growing
and growing without limit and redirecting
all the resources of the body to itself until
it ultimately kills the body.
Monopoly is cancer within capitalism, and
our bodies have an immune system that we're
constantly every day where our bodies are
producing cancerous cells in our immune system
is gobbling them up.
This is just a normal part of biology.
Well, similarly, you know, we developed an
immune system and capitalism is really in
its modern form.
Only about three hundred years old.
And back in the nineteen eighties here in
the United States, we developed an immune
system following on what had been done in
Europe just before, too.
That cancer of monopoly, which was the Sherman
Antitrust Act, and then later in the nineteen
thirties, the Clayton Antitrust Act and then
the 1956 Antitrust Act or Antimonopoly Law.
And you know, it worked, too, worked fairly
well.
But the problem was in nineteen eighty two,
nineteen eighty three, Ronald Reagan ordered
the Justice Department, the S.E.C. and the
Commerce Department to stop enforcing those
laws.
And that led to this explosion of consolidation,
the mergers and acquisition mania, those people
old enough to remember it.
It was a wild time.
Michael Milken.
And, you know, greed is good.
And all this stuff and all these companies
being jammed together and the workers being
fired, the pension funds, funds being stolen.
Most people remember the airlines DPW day
and Easter.
And then, you know, the guy got it this way.
But it happened in every sector of American
business.
And now here, 40 years later, there is not
literally not one single industrial sector
or major sector of the American economy left
that is not dominated by three to five large
companies that control 60 to 80 percent of
the total revenue and operate as functionally
as a monopoly.
Technically, you'd call it an oligopoly as
a result of this.
The average American family is paying about
five thousand dollars a year more for the
goods and services that they buy than they
would if we didn't have a monopoly.
Internet service, for example, in Europe is
typically twenty five to thirty dollars a
month for one gigabyte.
Up and down here in the United States, you
pay two to three times that because we've
got just a handful of Internet service providers.
Now, what I wanted to ask about the 5000,
because they think that that's interesting.
So when you write in the book.
That the monopoly in the United States essentially
expands or increases the amount that the average
family spends on a yearly basis by five thousand
dollars, and what you're talking about, there
would be well, on Internet, it might be an
additional sixty dollars a month, times 12.
Then you've got 720.
What what are the other areas?
Where is it on services, pharmaceuticals.
You know, basically everything except cheap
junk from China.
And and and what the cheap junk from China
has succeeded in doing is running out of business.
Literally thousands of American American companies
know since the 1980s we've been losing, you
know, on average seven, eight hundred factories
a year, in some cases thousands of factories
a year.
We were up to losing 5000 factories a year.
You know, after the after signing NAFTA and
and each one of those factories represents
hundreds to thousands, in some cases even
tens of thousands of jobs, according to the
Commerce Department.
According to our official statistics, we've
lost millions of jobs to to to this kind of
monopolistic behavior.
Only in this case, the monopoly is another
country, you know.
And, you know, a little help from Wal-Mart
and their friends.
So, you know, it's right across the board.
David, how has the when you look at the lack
of appetite to really deal with this in the
United States dating back for some time?
You talked about Ronald Reagan.
You've talked about it in the 18th century.
Is it as simple as a sort of version of regulatory
capture and a calculation from those in power
that this is just not where the regulatory
oversight is?
What an area that they want to focus?
Or is there more to it than that?
Well, by and large, that's how it's played
out.
But they're there, as usual.
The story is a little more complicated and
a little seamy or weirder.
You know, back in the 1960s, Milton Friedman
was teaching at the University of Chicago
and or was at the University of Chicago.
And one of his students, Robert Bork, got
all inflamed about this idea, all the hair
on fire, about this idea that he had learned
from Milton Friedman that that we shouldn't.
Traditionally, America had viewed a corporation
as having multiple constituencies.
A corporation had a responsibility to the
community in which it operated to not mistreat
that community or pollute to its employees,
to pay them well and serve them to its customers,
to make sure its customers weren't ripped
off or burned to the institution of the corporation
itself and to its shareholders and senior
management.
And Bork came along and said, all that is
nonsense.
You guys have complicated this way too much.
It's really simple.
If consumers pay less, then it's not a monopoly.
And, you know, people thought he was a crackpot
60s, but he persisted.
He wrote a book about it.
He testified to Congress.
He engaged a multi-year major lobbying campaign.
And by the time Reagan tried to put him on
the Supreme Court and we discovered that he
would not only was a crackpot, but also a
racist and a homophobe.
By that time, the Supreme Court in the 1970s,
in a case called GTP, Silvania had concluded
that Bork was right and that, you know, and
that Reagan was right and that we're going
to set all this stuff aside and we're only
going to enforce the antimonopoly laws based
on whether prices are going up for consumers.
Of course, since then, prices have caught
up on consumers tremendously.
But, you know, basically the enforcement was
killed.
So we're back right now where we were in nineteen
hundred.
You know, and we're faced with a situation
like the one that Teddy Roosevelt and William
Howard Taft took out.
Correct me if I'm wrong, but it seems that
that the Corona virus pandemic has really
accelerated the consolidation of market share
for the players that were already some of
the biggest players.
I mean, we're seeing with Amazon, Wal-Mart,
places that immediately scaled up, particularly
those that are that that use if they're using
these third party sprinter vans to deliver
stuff, that is a sign, if you work backwards,
that those are the the players that are increasing
market share.
And I just don't think we would need a total
rethink of the economy to prevent that from
naturally happening in a situation like the
one we find ourselves in.
Right.
I mean it from my perspective.
What the virus exposed was that a bunch of
the economy is significantly more fragile
than what we like to believe on a day to day
basis.
And as soon as that became clear, those that
were positioned to seize on the opportunity
have done so.
Yeah.
I mean, the reason why so many AIDS patients
died of Kaposi's sarcoma a cancer is because
their immune system is been shut down and,
you know, so cancer could grow in the body.
The reason why Monopoly has now seized America
and our economy is being run by a couple of
hundred billionaires is because that is because
Ronald Reagan stripped away our immune system.
He gave us the business equivalent of AIDS.
And and, you know, our country is suffering
terribly for it.
We've got to bring back that immune system.
We've got to be pushing back against the cancer
monopoly.
So what's the infrastructure that you think
needs needs to be put in place?
Is it as simple as just enforcing what is
on the books?
Or do we actually need a new framework in
which we are going to approach this issue?
Well, as is so often the case with with, you
know, proper structural problems in modern
America, so much of this goes back to the
Supreme Court.
You know, my last book was all about that
and actually the book before last.
And, you know, between the court and 78, 76
and 78, giving billionaires and corporations
the right to own politicians and entire political
parties and calling it free speech, combined
with the G.T.
Silvania case, where the court read, you know,
re understood explicit monopoly laws, the
antimonopoly laws explicitly talk about these
multiple constituencies and how you determine,
you know, everything.
And the cautious at all.
You know, we're gonna draw all that and go
with Robert Bork.
You know, we need legislation that includes
a court stripping provision, which I write
about my Supreme Court that overturns that
Supreme Court decision and the ones that have
followed and that reregulate American business
in a way that prevents it from being cancerous.
If you have the idea that if Joe Biden wins
in November and put somebody like Elizabeth
Warren, who has spoken about the issue of
Monopoly as secretary of commerce, for example,
or in some regulatory role, is it naive to
think that that alone might make a difference?
Like, is this just way bigger than that?
I think that America is poised on the edge
of the possibility of a another great renewal.
It seems like roughly every 80 years we go
through a crisis.
And then as we come out of the crisis, on
the back end weeks, we experience a renewal
explosion, the crisis of 1770 that led to
the American Revolution and the crisis of
the Civil War and the oligarchy in the south.
And that led to the civil war, but also led
to all the changes the post civil war changes,
very positive changes.
You had the great crash of 1929, the Republican
Great Depression that led to the New Deal
and all those changes.
You know, a smaller crisis, the assassination
of Jack Kennedy led to Medicare, Medicaid,
Civil Rights Act, Voting Rights Act, etc..
And I think that the crisis of the Trump presidency
and this giant drifter on job, the billionaires
have been running on us has set the stage
for a renewal.
The question is, No.
One, can we get a Democrat elected now?
Or as Trump so corrupted Americans, America's
electoral systems that that he's going to
turn us into?
You know, Trump is.
And number two, if we do get a Democratic
administration, whether they will have the
vision and the boldness to go ahead.
If if Elizabeth Warren is at the helm or is
has a substantial say in it, wherever that
may be and however it may play out, I'm very
enthusiastic and very excited and very hopeful.
If she gets marginalized and it becomes, you
know, basically a reinvention of the Clinton
and Obama presidencies, that we're deeply
in the pockets of large corporations, then,
you know, I'm I'm concerned.
But that's a that's a debate and a discussion
we can have once we once we put our you know,
our house is on fire right now.
You're out.
Yeah.
First, you put the fire out before you figure
out how to do how to fix what what what's
been burned.
Let's not discuss how to paint the rooms.
Yeah.
Right.
The searching for that analogy.
And you found it less.
The last thing on this.
There's an entire political movement in the
United States which heavily fetishizes the
idea of eliminating regulation, which is hampering
and restricting business, et cetera, et cetera.
How much of this is going to be an uphill
battle until that starts to be dealt with
as well?
Well, this is where we've got a big job to
do in educating the American people, because
the simple fact of the matter is that there
is only one force on Earth that can constrain
or restrain a billion dollar corporation when
it wants to pollute the water, put poison
in the air, kill people with crappy products,
oppress workers and rip off their employees.
There's only literally one power on Earth
that can fight back against that.
And that's government.
And, you know, the right wing billionaires,
you know, the Koch brothers and their buddies
back in the day knew that.
They understood that.
When their boy, Ronald Reagan, got elected,
they, you know, in his first inaugural address,
in his four minutes after he was sworn into
office, his first speech, he said government
is not the solution to problem.
Government is the problem.
He laid the he set the table for this destruction
of America.
That's been going on for 40 years.
And and, you know, it is some serious repair
work that needs to be done.
But I think if enough people wake up and realize
how badly we have been harmed by this bizarre
small government ideology that was only promoted
over these 40 years by people who simply wanted
to be able to pollute and poison and rip off
it with impunity, then I think that there's
some considerable hope.
The book is The Hidden History of Monopoly's
How Big Business Destroyed the American Dream?
We've been speaking with the book's author,
Thom Hartmann.
Tom, it's always so good to talk to you.
Thank you, David.
It's always not our pleasure to be on.